[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la cop 26 que se celebra estos días en
glasgow escocia con la emergencia
climática encima de la mesa nos
acompañan en este estudio tres
compañeras que conocen muy bien el
cambio climático marta torres
subdirectora de investigación en la
sorbona bienvenida buenos días gracias a
ti gracias periodista en france anfo
especialista en temas de medio ambiente
bienvenida a matilde lorena torres
investigadora en sense x lion
especialista en cuestiones del agua
bienvenida a lorena craft y desde
glasgow en la cob 26 periodista
especializada en cambio climático
mariana castaño buenos días mariana
buenas tardes karlos encantada de estar
con vosotros
la emergencia climática y la cop 26 hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
ya saben que estos días se celebra en
glasgow la cob 26 la conferencia de
naciones unidas sobre el cambio
climático bajo la premisa de lograr
acuerdos rápidos para combatir la
emergencia climática los expertos siguen
diciendo que la próxima década será
crucial para invertir la tendencia y
solo una acción radical ayudará a evitar
impactos catastróficos para a partir de
ahí de la evidencia científica que ya
pocos se atreven a negar arranca el
campo de las voluntades políticas y de
un replanteamiento del sistema y de
nuestras formas de consumo hasta donde
estamos dispuestos a renunciar como
sociedad y como individuos para salvar
al planeta y sobre todo una presión
ciudadana hacia los políticos es la
única vía lo vamos a analizar hoy en el
programa antes repasemos algunas
portadas even in standard en reinounido
la foto de boris johnson en el inicio de
la cob y el titular la historia será
nuestro juez a quien francia el qb
hunter nacional el futuro nos pertenece
dice la publicación que todavía hay
razones para guardar esperanza pese al
ambiente de escepticismo y en américa
latinael correo del sur en bolivia se
hace eco de uno de los primeros
compromisos acordados en la cob de dar
fin con la deforestación en 2030 bueno
marta podemos hablar de última
oportunidad en esta con 26 o es
demasiado es un poco demasiado es una
fecha importante
porque es cuando se va a determinar si
el acuerdo de parís del 2015 realmente
tiene un sentido y se va a saber si hay
cuestiones que se zanjan o no se zanjan
pero no es la última oportunidad y no
hay que pensar las han pasado seis años
desde la cop de parís
recordemos que el acuerdo de parís era
limitar el calentamiento global a más 15
grados
apunta a leer esto ya sería un éxito de
esta con 26 si ya hay acuerdos o
objetivos nuevos de los estados que
dejan pensar que podría ser un éxito en
ese sentido porque la agencia
internacional de energía ahora dice que
podríamos limitar el calentamiento
global a un grado otro que es mucho
mejor que el 2 grados 7 que se escuchaba
mucho antes de la cob pero hay que
repetir que solo son objetivos y el
compromiso de los estados ahora hay que
implementar todo eso y tenemos mucho
retraso todos los países es claro y está
con 26 además llegan un momento muy
especial después de la pandemia durante
la pandemia ha habido un periodo de
standby donde las emisiones lógicamente
se habían reducido pero ahora la
economía vuelve y lógicamente las
emisiones vuelven a niveles de antes de
la pandemia sí exacto por eso está
representa un momento
definitorio para eso exactamente como
como los estados van a crear mecanismos
vinculatorios en términos jurídicos
porque recordemos que en 2018 ya se
había hecho un libro para echar a andar
todo lo que se había acordado en 2015 y
es 2021 y sigue en construcción es el
libro de reglas para implementar el
acuerdo el acuerdo de parís entonces hay
instrumentos que se quedaron en el
camino durante seis años y que realmente
la pandemia está replanteando los en
términos también de cuáles son las
prioridades ahora que los estados deben
de poner en sus agendas en sus agendas
nacionales también y con visión global
vamos a pulsar la temperatura vamos a
irnos hasta glasgow en este punto hasta
la cob 26 con la periodista mariana
castaño especializada en cambio
climático que está cubriendo toda la
cumbre lo primero mariana ya que estás
sobre terreno que ambiente se vive allá
el de una verdadera última oportunidad
el escepticismo respecto a las
voluntades políticas impregna el
ambiente allí también
el sentimiento carlos es un sentimiento
entre mezclado por un lado los
participantes de la cob se ven que están
contentos de poder reunirse después de
dos años sin haber llevado a cabo por un
lado reuniones de negociación formales y
por otro lado reuniones para mostrar los
avances en acción climática en el sector
de las empresas
pero por otro lado estamos viendo por un
informe científico detrás de otro la
situación es crítica entonces llegamos
tarde y lo que no queremos es llegar mal
o no llegar peor de lo que salimos el 25
en madrid los sentimientos son así
encontrados pero sí es cierto que
después de eso primero está limpio que
vivimos el lunes y el martes sobre todo
en los ámbitos de reforestación y de
control de metano hay cierto aire de
optimismo en el ambiente esperemos que
no se difumine en éstas
buenos sentimientos encontrados nos dice
mariana pero es verdad que un poco de
esperanza en estos primeros acuerdos que
hemos empezado a ver lo repasamos más de
80 países han prometido recordar
recortar un 30 por ciento de sus
emisiones de metano en 2030 hablamos
poco del metano que suponen estas
emisiones no sé quién quiera marta
supone muchísimo porque el metano es uno
de los gases de efecto invernadero de
los más importantes y lo que me parece
un poco extraordinario es que se empieza
a hablar del metano en el 2021 cuando se
habla de gases de efecto invernadero en
su globalidad desde los años 70 incluso
desde los años 60 entonces llega un poco
tarde vale más tarde que nunca pero es
un poquito peculiar sobre todo ahora que
se dice que es la cob de la última
oportunidad y es como que se sacan del
sombrero como un mago mira ahora tenemos
lo del metano vamos vamos a hacer cosas
también con el metano es como que hasta
ahora sólo se ha hablado del carbono y
ahí 6 gases efecto invernadero entonces
bueno lo veo bien pero me parece un
poquito
sorprendente y también es verdad que de
repente ahora nos podemos hablar del
metano en 2021 sí claro porque el metano
es un gas muy nocivo para el clima
viene de la agricultura y también de la
energía de las
centrales que emiten un poco de metano
es un tema muy importante para el bayern
en eeuu que tiene que pasar como hacer
una legislación sobre el tema para para
cambiar en el muy importante también un
centenar de países se compromete a
salvar los bosques en 2030 la
deforestación debe atenderse con la
misma seriedad que la descarbonización
de las economías y por supuesto sobre
todo cuando en los últimos años estamos
viendo que muchos gobiernos se están
tendiendo a
a un cambio hacia la deforestación pero
por otra parte están implementando
mecanismos de
deforestación total para esta entrada
también de los mercados de carbono
entonces
sí debe de haber mayor rigidez sobre
todo en términos de las leyes que se
están implementando a nivel nacional
para fortalecer la parte de
reforestación pero en términos reales
también lo cierto es que si no se
alcanzan los objetivos establecidos en
acuerdo de parís los investigadores
muestran que con la trayectoria actual
de emisiones la temperatura global
aumentará entre 3 y 4 grados en los
próximos 80 años y esto causará daños
irreversibles hay una toma conciencia
real de esto ya es decir a nivel
ciudadano eso sí ya se visualiza esa
conciencia yo creo que cada vez más
precisamente por toda esa cantidad de
incendios forestales por ejemplo que ha
habido en amazonas y en otras zonas del
mundo en estos últimos años en europa ha
habido unos incendios que no habíamos
conocido hasta ahora canículas subidas
de temperatura inundación es bastante
importante es que hacen que las personas
que tienen una casa en la playa muy
concretamente ven las orejas al lobo y
se dan cuenta de que la cosa está siendo
grave y seria ahora hace falta más
esfuerzos claro
hay una toma de conciencia a nivel
ciudadano a mí me pareció que empezó en
el
verano de 2018 cuando una canícula muy
importante en francia y las los
incendios en las amazonas y también en
septiembre el ministro del medio
ambiente que es muy conocido que era muy
conocido empresa que se llama nicola
glóbulo salió del gobierno y dijo no
estamos a la altura del desafío del
cambio climático y del medio ambiente en
general y luego llegó a greta y los
jóvenes salieron a
manifestarse mucho yo creo que en 2018
fue realmente un cambio en la
movilización de la juventud pero también
de toda la gente tener un referente como
la figura de creta a la que se refería a
till ha sido importante también hay
muchos jóvenes a veces tener referente
moviliza mucho más que un discurso
artículos de prensa o que las corts no
por supuesto la figura de creta es
sumamente relevante sobre todo en los
últimos años porque llegó a ocupar un
espacio que había mucha necesidad de
ocupar la voz de los jóvenes pero sobre
todo esa representación de las minorías
porque ella representa esta voz de los
jóvenes que sabemos qué está pasando
tenemos conciencia de lo que está
pasando y queremos actuar y queremos
tomar la palabra porque sabemos cómo se
debe hacer pero también se ha vuelto voz
de otros grupos minoritarios como los
grupos indígenas mujeres indígenas
entonces creo que representa la
ocupación de un espacio que se tenía que
ocupar desde desde los 90 y es curioso
lo que a algunos les molesta la figura
de greta también por la a veces por la
no voy a ser radicalidad del discurso
sino la sinceridad a veces de su
discurso hacer sentir culpable eso no
hay nada peor en el mundo que te hagan
sentir culpable de algo y eso lo hace
bueno y en este punto volvemos a glasgow
balakov 26 con la periodista mariana
castaño mariana con qué criterios o
parámetros podríamos considerar que la
con 26 ha sido todo un éxito
desde un punto de vista puramente de la
negociación está claro que tienen que
cerrarse los temas que quedaron
pendientes en la 25 de madrid luego en
cuanto a la brecha de ambición es decir
que los compromisos la nds que están
sobre la mesa no estamos para llegar a
1.5 de límite de la temperatura
hace unos días estamos ya por 2,7 grados
centígrados
tenemos en estos ocho días que nos
quedan por delante señales claras de que
esa brecha de la ambición se va a
superar y por otro lado la brecha de la
solidaridad y ahí me refiero a los 100
mil millones de dólares que ayuda a los
países en desarrollo y ayuda para acción
climática que no están y apenas se llega
a los 80 mil millones anuales y los
países en desarrollo sobre todo los
menos desarrollados ya están diciendo
que no son 100 mil millones anuales sino
muchos son armados que hacen claro es
que luego está la cuestión de ayudar a
los países en desarrollo países que nos
dicen ustedes han contaminado desde la
época de la revolución industrial porque
ahora nosotros no lo podemos hacer no
podemos desarrollarlos y adquirir esos
estándares de vida
vamos a decirnos en este punto de hacer
una breve pausa si les parece y en unos
instantes les pregunto por esto y
también por la cuestión ciudadana por el
compromiso ciudadana será a vuelta de
pausa quien en primera plana gracias
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días
intuitivo rápido y en cuatro lenguas
france24 puntocom liberté égalité
actualice
[Música]
y
casi un centenar de personas murieron en
sierra leona tras la explosión de un
camión cisterna muchas de las víctimas
fallecieron tras intentar recoger un
poco de combustible que transportaba el
vehículo más de 100 personas también
resultaron heridas en el incidente
en el día global de la justicia
climática comenzó en glasgow una
multitudinaria marcha que aspira a
reunir hasta 100.000 personas también
hubo manifestaciones en ciudades como
sydney y seúl donde piden que los
líderes tomen acciones más concretas
para combatir el cambio climático
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó el plan de infraestructura de 12
millones de dólares que ya había sido
sancionado por el senado al proyecto
considerado uno de los emblemas del
mandato de joe biden solo le falta la
firma del jefe de estado para que pueda
entrar en vigor
buenos días en américa y bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias de france 24 yo
soy mar y clara calle
comenzamos en áfrica al menos 99
personas murieron en la capital de
sierra leona freetown según el
ministerio de salud cerca de 100
personas más resultaron heridas todo por
una explosión de un camión cisterna que
se estrelló el alto número de víctimas
es en gran parte porque muchas personas
se aglomeraron alrededor del coche para
intentar recoger combustible según dijo
la alcaldía algunas duras imágenes
muestran como el fuego arrasaba con
tiendas y casas cercanas horas después
se pronunció el presidente julius manda
avión a través de su cuenta de twitter
estoy profundamente consternado por los
trágicos incendios y la horrenda pérdida
de vidas en la zona de wellington mi más
sentido pésame a las familias que han
perdido sus seres queridos y a las que
han quedado mutiladas como consecuencia
de ello mi gobierno hará todo lo posible
para apoyar a las familias afectadas
en glasgow ya comenzó una de las marchas
más fuertes de esta jornada de protestas
en todo el mundo para pedir acciones
contra el cambio climático en la ciudad
escocesa donde se realiza la cob 26
esperan que más de 100.000 personas se
unan a las manifestaciones al final
habrá discursos de varios activistas
ambientales incluyendo las reconocidas
creta schönberg y vanessa and acate
también hay marchas en 200 puntos del
mundo como seúl río de janeiro y ciudad
de méjico mientras los manifestantes
exigen más acciones 45 países se
comprometieron en la cob 26 a
intensificar la protección de la
naturaleza y revisar la reducción de
emisiones de la agricultura uno de los
sectores más contaminantes las
propuestas son por el día mundial de la
justicia climática previamente nuestra
enviada especial a glasgow marina
colorado explico qué significa este
concepto qué significa esto lo que piden
es que se trate a la crisis climática
más allá de la meteorología más allá de
la economía más allá del lenguaje
técnico y científico y se incluyan los
derechos humanos en la lucha y en las
decisiones que se tomen piden que se
tengan en cuenta las inequidades
sociales económicas y poblacionales que
esta crisis climática está teniendo en
la población fue un término acuñado en
el hemisferio sur para pedir que los
países más responsables de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero se hagan
responsables y compensen a los países
menos emisores que sufren las
consecuencias más dramáticamente
marín a colorado también nos explicó que
son las soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza que se discutieron hoy en la
cumbre climática pues consiste en
aprovechar los recursos naturales en
beneficio de la sociedad y del medio
ambiente es decir en lugar de
aprovecharse de estos recursos talando
árboles quemando pastos y dejando
extensiones enormes de tierra lo que se
pretende es utilizar precisamente el
system natural que el planeta tierra
creó y que funciona perfectamente en
equilibrio si lo dejáramos tranquilo que
esos sistemas funcionen y sigan intactos
y que podamos convivir con ellos de
manera sostenible por ejemplo ayudar que
por ejemplo los humedales hagan de
sumideros de agua para evitar
inundaciones también dejará los
manglares intactos para que frenen el
impacto de los huracanes en zonas
costeras o también el silvopastoreo que
es dejar árboles y dejar las plantas que
crecen naturalmente en ciertos
ecosistemas para que el ganado pueda
comer de esas plantas y no tener que
talar y usar grandes partes de la tierra
del suelo para llevar a cabo estas
prácticas
pasamos a alemania la policía registró
un ataque con cuchillo en un tren de
alta velocidad que viajaba entre las
ciudades de regensburg y nuremberg en el
sur del país hubo varios heridos aunque
las autoridades todavía no precisan
cuantos el sospechoso fue arrestado y
alrededor de 200 personas fueron
evacuadas del tren el portavoz de la
policía afirmó que no hay evidencia de
que otros atacantes estuvieran
involucrados y prófugos
en eeuu la cámara de representantes
aprobó el proyecto de infraestructura
por 12 billones de dólares uno de los
planes bandera del presidente joe biden
el objetivo es mejorar carreteras
puentes y la red de internet durante la
próxima década además es una victoria
para el partido demócrata que por varios
meses intentó conseguir la aprobación a
pesar de las divisiones internas todavía
falta que se apruebe el proyecto de
gasto social manuel acá no nos explica
aprobado el plan de infraestructura tras
meses de incertidumbre la cámara de
representantes estadounidense le dio el
visto bueno a uno de los pilares de la
campaña del presidente joe wagner el
proyecto de ley de infraestructura prevé
dedicar algo más de un billón de dólares
a la mejora de redes de transporte en
todo el país la ampliación de la
distribución de energía y el incremento
de la banda ancha de internet el segundo
proyecto de ley es un conjunto de
reformas más amplio se trata de su plan
de gasto social que constaría de 1.75
billones de dólares pero ha quedado
pospuesto hasta mediados de noviembre
hemos esperado bastante y esperábamos
aprobarla antes pero no podemos esperar
mucho más por la legislación de hoy sí
creo que hay un gran número de miembros
de caucus progresista que votarán para
aprobar este proyecto de ley
una cuarta parte del presupuesto para
gasto social se destinaría a la lucha
contra el cambio climático mientras que
otras propuestas incluyen la
financiación de la educación preescolar
universal un límite a los costes de las
guarderías el cuidado de los ancianos y
la inmigración reformas más difíciles de
aprobar con publicanos unidos en la
oposición al proyecto de ley los
demócratas necesitarán casi todos los
votos a su alcance para que sea aprobado
por la cámara de representantes y los
demócratas moderados centristas
mantienen sus reservas y en una
estimación de costes no partidista antes
de decidir si respaldan el plan esa
estimación podría tardar hasta dos
semanas la aprobación del plan de
infraestructura constituye un triunfo
para joe biden quien esperaría una nueva
victoria con el plan de gasto social
para el día de acción de gracias
vayamos a houston texas porque al menos
ocho personas murieron y otras 17 fueron
llevadas a los hospitales a causa de una
estampida en el festival de música astro
world 11 de ellas con paro cardíaco
además unas 300 personas presentaron
heridas leves este hecho ocurrió cuando
la multitud comenzó a empujar hacia el
escenario los motivos aún se desconocen
y solo se sabe que la avalancha humana
se produjo durante el concierto del
rapero travis scott él detuvo varias
veces el show cuando vio que fanáticos
de las filas delanteras pedían ayuda
esto dijeron las autoridades locales
lo que sabemos es que aproximadamente a
las nueve en punto nueve y quince la
multitud comenzó a comprimirse es el
frente del escenario eso causó pánico y
comenzó a causar algunos heridos datos
son parc
las personas comenzaron a caer a perder
el conocimiento y eso generó más palmas
coches y el destino de su padre en
noticias de américa latina' el partido
oficialista de nicaragua le pide a los
ciudadanos que asistan a las urnas este
domingo por su parte la oposición y los
nicaragüenses exiliados promueven la
abstención en las presidenciales y es
que muchos dudan de la legitimidad
porque siete candidatos opositores han
sido detenidos no hay observadores
internacionales y el gobierno prohibió
el ingreso de emisiones periodísticas al
país sin embargo rosario murillo
vicepresidenta y esposa del mandatario
daniel ortega asegura que los comicios
se realizan en paz
veamos cómo está el ambiente electoral
en una de las notas de nuestra serie
especial
la certeza del vencedor una nicaragua
sin campaña política en las avenidas del
país no hay ninguna alusión a las
elecciones generales del próximo 7 de
noviembre la previsión de los resultados
es tal que ni el oficialista frente
sandinista hace publicidad sus
seguidores deben comprarse un souvenir
si desean honrar a su partido desde
antes del 19 landry buscando y no al
ayer y ahora que tuve la oportunidad de
venir aquí y la puedo comparar la compré
enrique núñez consiguió una bandera del
partido sandinista aunque extraña las
épocas cuando el presidente daniel
ortega se tomaba el tiempo para
conseguir votos yo me acuerdo cuando yo
estaba chiquito él llegó una vez a la
intendencia allá del mercado oriental y
yo lo vi persona de persona cara a cara
no como ahora porque cuesta ser barceló
ahí lo tuve yo a la par las elecciones
han causado controversia porque siete
candidatos de oposición están
encarcelados y varios partidos fueron
suspendidos por el órgano electoral para
este politólogo ortega ir a unas
elecciones sin competencia prácticamente
los candidatos
todo ha sido colaboracionistas
son gentes desconocidas prácticamente
para el público en general y si por
añadidura no tienen o no hacen
propaganda quién va a ir a votar por
ellos aparte digamos de que mucha gente
está decidida a no votar porque
prácticamente el frente eliminó a los
que desgraciadamente le podían hacer
oposición ortega de 75 años aspira a su
cuarto mandato consecutivo como
presidente su esposa rosario murillo
también busca reelegirse como
vicepresidente del país hasta ahora los
lugares de venta de camisetas y
souvenirs políticos son los espacios
donde se siente un ambiente electoral en
nicaragua el presidente daniel ortega no
necesita invertir en promoción su
triunfo es casi un hecho
ocho grupos rebeldes de etiopía se
unieron a las fuerzas de tigre desde
washington anunciaron la creación de una
alianza contra el gobierno del primer
ministro abhisit med la comunidad
internacional llama a la paz y eeuu le
pidió a sus ciudadanos que abandonen el
país inmediatamente
todos unidos contra el primer ministro
de etiopía el viernes nueve grupos
rebeldes unificados bajo el nombre de
frente unido de fuerzas federalistas y
confederalistas de qiu quienes
declararon que juntaran sus fuerzas
contra el oficialismo a 6 pons de esta
alianza se forman respuesta a las
numerosas crisis del país para revertir
los efectos negativos del gobierno de
abbey ahmed en el pueblo de etiopía y en
otros lugares por feaps envió los
distintos grupos son poco conocidos al
igual que sus capacidades reales serían
procedentes de diferentes religiones y
etnias sobre el terreno los rebeldes del
frente de liberación del pueblo de tigre
y de lola un grupo romo ya habían
degradado la unión de sus tropas y
habían afirmado tener el control de dos
ciudades estratégicas
unos 300 kilómetros de la capital addis
abeba una ciudad que se prepara para una
seguridad además de la declaración de
reciente del estado de emergencia
nacional y de una movilización de
hombres y armas el viernes ex soldados y
reservistas fueron llamados a las filas
sin embargo el gobierno sigue negando al
avance del enemigo mientras los llamados
a la paz de la comunidad internacional
siguen sin escucharse el conflicto en
etiopía debe terminar las negociaciones
de paz deben comenzar inmediatamente sin
condiciones previas para lograr un alto
al fuego desde hace un año chupi a vive
una guerra civil la que según la onu ha
dejado miles de muertos y ha obligado a
dos millones de civiles a abandonar sus
hogares
y para terminar una noticia en brasil
donde la famosa cantautora marilia
mendoza murió en un accidente de avión
la avioneta en la que viajaba junto a
otras tres personas se estrelló en una
zona rural del estado de minas gerais y
todos los ocupantes fallecieron en dos a
era una de las principales voces de la
música country en brásil
[Música]
cinco años de fama y 26 cortos años de
vida marilia mendonça la mega estrella
brasileña de la música country ha muerto
en un accidente aéreo se dirigía a dar
un concierto en caratinga en el estado
suroriental de minas gerais el productor
de la ganadora del grammy latino su tío
y los dos pilotos también murieron la
policía ya abrió una investigación
los restos de una antena sugieren que el
avión colisionó con ella antes de caer
gracias
[Música]
con su canción infiel sobre el engaño
mendonça saltó a la fama nacional en
2016 relaciones fallidas y
empoderamiento femenino el tema resultó
ser una fórmula ganadora y lanzó un
éxito tras otro acumulando miles de
millones de visitas en youtube y
convirtiéndose en la artista más
escuchada de spotify en brasil en 2019 y
2020 su amigo íntimo el futbolista
neymar tuiteó que se negaba a creer lo
ocurrido el presidente ayer bolsonaro
declaró por su parte que todo el país
estaba conmocionado por el fallecimiento
de una de las mayores artistas de su
generación
además de su legado de ofrecer una
perspectiva femenina en un género del
musical tradicionalmente machista
conocido como el ser tan hijo marilia
mendonça deja atrás a su hijo que
cumplirá dos años el próximo mes
[Música]
y hasta aquí nuestra emisión informativa
pero esperen más actualizaciones en
minutos sigan conectados con nosotros
[Música]
continuamos en primera plana esta semana
analizando la cob 26 y la emergencia
climática lo hacemos con las
investigadoras es marta torres saw y
lorena torres y la periodista matt y la
gracia de frança fue nuestra compañera
mariana castaño desde la cob 26 en
glasgow hablamos antes de los
compromisos y de la voluntad política
pero claro si los compromisos se
traducen en una verdadera acción
política en los países esto no supone
claramente más impuestos para el
ciudadano es decir sacrificios no
forzosamente porque hay lo que se llama
la redistribución es la justicia
redistributiva
entonces habría que repensar en qué se
utilizan los impuestos con respecto a lo
que se está utilizando ahora hay varios
países que se han comprometido han hecho
el anuncio me parece que fue ayer en la
cob de que van a dejar de financiar
a las energías fósiles y a todas este
tipo de mecanismo económico bueno si se
empieza a redistribuir un poco la
riqueza de esa manera las inversiones
del estado los impuestos también se
pueden reorganizar también parece que es
por ese lado por el que tiene que ir no
tiene por qué haber más sacrificio
económico del ciudadano lambda sino que
es una cuestión de repensar cómo se
utiliza el dinero ahora pero pongamos
ejemplos concretos por ejemplo tomar un
avión
tendrá que estar más tasado tendrá que
tener unas tasas extras el hecho de
tomar un avión es decir que forzosamente
va a pasar a ser un producto más
exclusivo más reservado para un cierto
nivel adquisitivo tampoco con
forzosamente porque las compañías aéreas
ahora reciben subvenciones se les puede
seguir dando subvenciones a condición de
que ellas también inviertan en ciertas
técnicas en tecnologías que utilizan
menos energía fósil entonces no tiene
por qué aumentar eso el precio del avión
pueden seguir habiendo aviones porque
hay gente que necesita seguir
desplazándose no por ocio sino realmente
por necesidad familiar o de trabajo y no
tiene por qué aumentar el precio no
tiene por qué ser sólo para una élite
eso sería muy injusto simplemente lo que
hay que mirar a ver es que como se ayuda
a las compañías aéreas y como ellas
también se van a reorganizar y se van a
hacer verdes en cualquier caso estamos
hablando de ecología y del otro concepto
que está comentando un vídeo en marta
justicia social en cualquier caso va a
ser difícil conjugar todo esto conjugar
justicia social con salvar el planeta va
a ser un rompecabezas para muchos
gobiernos
lorena es precisamente la relevancia de
esta cop como traduces esas dos ideas
que son fundamentales como esta famosa
frase de no hay justicia climática sin
justicia social es totalmente cierta y
entonces como traduce eso en los
acuerdos en todo lo que se va atroz en
todo lo que se va a hacer en la cope
precisamente poniendo fechas poniendo
límites poniendo instituciones como vas
a transparentar eso vuelve a ser la
prioridad de financiamiento en el nivel
de impuestos cuáles van a ser las
prioridades en los gobiernos nacionales
a que se están comprometiendo ellos con
la agenda global
donde concretamente se tienen que
establecer prioridades políticas y de
financiamiento para influir en estos
procesos que son además de conciencia y
cognitivos de las personas que crecimos
con este proceso ya insertos en el
capitalismo y matilde justicia social
como entra en la ecuación de la ecología
siempre se plantea el tema de los
chalecos amarillos claro mientras hemos
tenido un exponente muy potente de este
texto que hablamos que se subía el
precio de la del combustible y salieron
a la calle cientos de miles de franceses
que no aceptaban pagar más para el
combustible que necesitaban todos los
días para ir a trabajar por ejemplo y
así que se ve que si se impone si se
impone en tasas a toda la población va a
haber un problema y en ese año en 2018
cuando salieron dos chalecos amarillas
se planteó muchísimo el tema de la
justicia social como cómo se determina
quién va a pagar para
para más impuestos para bajar el consumo
de combustibles y si hacemos el subir
los impuestos es muy importante lo dicen
todos los los expertos para bajar el
consumo de energía fósiles pero quién va
a pagar mi empresa el problema la
pandemia de la cob y 19 ha significado
que los países comprensiblemente no se
hayan centrado únicamente en lograr los
objetivos establecidos la pandemia ha
causado trastornos económicos y sociales
volvemos en este punto al glasgow con
mariana castaño cómo transformar en
impulso la restauración económica
mariana
sin duda la pandemia del codis ha tenido
para mí dos consecuencias en el proceso
internación
por un lado lo positivo hacemos visto
que cuando se quiere se puede cuando las
naciones se quieren poner de acuerdo en
una causa común frente común y el llegar
a lograr obtener una vacuna ese es un
logro de la actividad internacional por
otro lado lo que se ha puesto de
manifiesto es que los planes de
recuperación del gobierno han puesto
sobre la mesa no son planes verdes
cuando se analizan los datos se ve que
está un porcentaje muy pequeño de la
recuperación va para proyectos que
realmente sean bajos en emisiones de
carbono o que generen una resiliencia
muy importante de estas reuniones de la
actividad civil a gente sin conexión a
los poderes tanto políticos como
económicos para que se alineen con esos
objetivos del acuerdo de parís y para
que cada euro cada dólar que se invierta
sea tenga en cuenta el impacto clima
otra cuestión sería si la humanidad es
capaz de renunciar a cosas en aras del
bienestar de futuras generaciones cuando
quizás nosotros ya no estemos aquí lo
complicado de proyectarse en esos
cuantos grados va a aumentar el planeta
el fin de siglo no hay una cuestión de
egoísmo antropológico a la hora de
replantear toda esta problemática marta
bueno hay ahí digamos y unos intereses
que a lo mejor no son los mismos porque
entre generaciones obviamente los
esfuerzos que tienen que hacer las
generaciones que llegan incluso la
nuestra ya empieza a tener que tener
esfuerzos todo eso es lo que hay que
poner sobre la mesa pero la noción de
justicia entre generaciones existe
también desde hace tiempo es una
cuestión que los filósofos plantean
desde hace tiempo que ahora los juristas
también se están haciendo con este tema
y que aparece además en el acuerdo de
parís en la parte del preámbulo todo
esto de justicia social y justicia entre
generaciones eso simplemente habría
efectivamente que ponerlo más claramente
sobre el papel y darse cuenta de que no
tenemos por qué imponer a los que
a tener 50 años en el 2030 o en 80 años
en el 2050
esfuerzos que les pongo ejemplos
prácticos después de la cob lo que va a
llegar es el black friday
es posible reducir emisiones manteniendo
este sistema de producción basado en el
consumo es decir existe un capitalismo
verde
yo no voy a contestar la pregunta es que
el capitalismo bien de verde cree que si
la tecnología nos puede salvar con
inversiones masivas en no sé por ejemplo
en año el macro dijo que se podía
invertir en la energía nuclear que no
emite carbono así que nos puede ayudar
mucha gente cree que la tecnología nos
puede ayudar a mantener el mismo nivel
de vida pero también muchos científicos
dicen que hay recursos límites en el
planeta así que tenemos que decrecer
para mantener un planeta habitable
lorena usted cree en eso del capitalismo
verde
o es algo incompatible es decir aquí
luego que estamos hablando de que hay
una incompatibilidad para salvar el
planeta a través del mismo sistema que
nos ha llevado hasta este punto hay que
replantear es la pregunta creo que
incluso ahí podríamos irnos a estas
teorías ya de los años 60-70 es que
hablaban de decrecimiento es más
cuestionar un poco un poco cómo hemos
crecido creo que revertir todo un
proceso de tantos de tantas decenas es
complicado pero creo que soy optimista
creo que podemos revertir ciertas
acciones a nivel individual con
mecanismos de acción pública
ahí es donde realmente el estado entra
en acción como establece criterios para
un poco establecer responsabilidades y
responsabilidades hacia los individuos
bueno dejamos este black friday como
dices pero
debes de estar consciente que esto va a
tener impactos al medio ambiente cambio
climático etcétera etcétera es tu
decisión porque yo voy a establecer
otros criterios en realidad es un poco
como el estado está estableciendo un
poco
mecanismos de de una democracia
climática
no sobre la culpa porque pareciera que
también estamos partiendo de una
democracia climática sobre la culpa
sobre tus acciones hacen daño cada cosa
que compras hace daño entonces pero
también eso es muy extremo porque cómo
revertimos lenta descargas sobre el
individuo toda esa carga de culpabilidad
marta si nada estoy de acuerdo pero
quería añadir quizá que más que decrecer
lo importante es sobriedad no es lo
mismo es decir que podemos seguir
viviendo digamos con cierto bienestar
porque bueno son cuestiones que se han
adquirido desde hace generaciones es
difícil revertir esa dinámica pero quizá
de manera más sobria está el black
friday pero luego va a estar navidad
y luego están las rebajas
de bruces contra la máxima del sistema
que tenemos que es transformar nuestros
deseos en posibilidades y al capital es
decir lo quiero lo tengo hay got it y
esa sobriedad no cuaja en esa ecuación
ciertamente es verdad que ahora vivimos
lo quiero todo en salud para la gente
aunque usted pueda no es una cuestión de
que usted se lo pueda permitir es una
cuestión de limitaciones en pos del bien
común y es complicado esto me parece que
el problema más importante es que
todavía no sabemos cómo ha de crecer
económicamente o imponer la sobriedad en
nuestros hábitos y mantener el empleo
que ahora el crecimiento significa
empleo para nosotros o sea no nos cuesta
mucho pensar en un sistema donde no haya
crecimiento para que todo el mundo tenga
trabajo en el transfondo leo brouwer a
mariana castaño en el trasfondo de todo
hay una cuestión que subyace en el de
admitir que sólo de crecer puede
salvarnos o no y que esto es que no
lograremos con este sistema que traduce
nuestros deseos en posibilidades como
decía antes vial capital no sé este
debate que toca la fibra más espiritual
de cada uno de nosotros también existen
los pasillos de la cob mariana
197 detectados muy diferentes la primera
potencia económica la país emergente y
los países menos desarrollados donde el
objetivo es sacar tela puede pesar
incluso de la pobreza energética a su
población entonces este debate de
decrecimiento hay que verlo desde un
punto de vista que no se ha centralizado
desde nuestro punto de vista cultural a
qué país a qué economía cuál en disfraz
realidades y hay que pensar realmente
dónde están los países
desarrollados
si bien la noción de
decrecimiento no se le puede aplicar a
todos los países no todos los sectores
sociales
claro hay una cuestión de justicia
social entre ciudadanos y también una
cuestión de justicia social entre países
es que es las capas de la justicia
social en todo este asunto claro claro
es el tema de la responsabilidad común
pero diferenciada
que ya aparece en la convención marco de
naciones unidades de cambio climático en
1992 es esa esa es la cuestión de fondo
entonces hay unas responsabilidades de
todos los países pero son diferenciadas
entonces no se puede impedir a ciertos
países de seguir desarrollándose eso no
quiere decir que sigan consumiendo de la
misma manera o que paul bien me quedo
sin tipo para más ha sido muy
interesante este programa con ustedes
muchísimas gracias lorena matilde marta
también a usted mariana castaño desde
glasgow y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana en primera plana gracias